[Music]
DT, how you doing?
Hey, what's up?
What's up? What's up?
Yes. Are you a Muslim?
Yes, I am. Alhamdulillah, I'm a Muslim.
Uh,
my question to you with sticking to
today's topic. Uh, before I put the
question in, uh, I just want to make it
uh, make a point that you're being quite
disingenuous because, you know, Muslims
will not mock Jesus Christ. We love
Jesus Christ. We absolutely respect him
and we not take any mockery about him.
To put Paul's name in line with Jesus
Christ, you're playing over here to show
that Paul is almost equal to Jesus
Christ, which is no way even possible.
So, I'm going to put that across. So,
let me let me respond to that really
quick and then I'll let you go on with
your next point. So, so I don't maybe
you're not on the internet a lot, so I I
can grant that that you're you're
probably unaware of what Muslims do. Um,
but Muslims all the time, especially
around the circles that I'm in, I'm on
TikTok a lot, and YouTube a lot, and
Muslims are constantly cursing Jesus.
They're putting pictures. Let me let me
finish with you, please.
Yes,
cuz I didn't interrupt you. Um, these
Muslims are uh cursing Jesus. They're
cursing the Holy Spirit. They're saying
that they um they piss on the cross.
They put pictures of a fake picture of a
Jesus um in a clown uniform on the cross
like Ronald McDonald. Um
you know, they um they put uh they make
Jesus like a like he's a like he's a a
crybaby. They they mock him crying on
the cross, you know, uh or crying in the
or praying in the garden of Gethsemane.
mock that and they'll and I'm not going
to do what they do exactly because it's
blasphemy, but they but they mock Jesus
in his prayers um when he's seeking the
father. And so I've I've seen this stuff
firsthand. I've seen this uh with my own
eyes. I've experienced it while on the
panel in Muslim panels when Muslims are
the moderators and the Muslims are the
hosts. They allow this stuff to happen.
This stuff goes on. And so maybe you're
unaware, maybe you do not know about
this stuff, which um you know, you know
that's your experience, but to say that
I'm being disingenuous
is a is a false judgment. So I just
wanted to respond to that.
Can I respond to that?
You can talk about Paul
respond to that because I am I'm on the
internet. I'm on the internet. I'm I'm
quite uh
you can respond to Paul and Jesus
name one.
So I'm going to go ahead and shut you up
now because now you're showing that
you're disingenuous. All right. So now
that that's been addressed already, I
would like for you to address the topic
if you can address how Jesus and Paul
are better than Muhammad. Um putting
Paul up there. Um, I'm trying to throw
you a u something that you could
probably address cuz obviously comparing
Paul and Muhammad I I'm sorry, Jesus and
Muhammad is completely unfair. Like
Muhammad can't even untie the shoes of
Jesus. He can't lick the bottom of his
sandal. That's how unworthy and unholy
he is compared to Jesus. I wanted to
bring somebody that's more humanly
um relatable, I guess you can say. Um,
even though it's the same and even
though Muhammad is infinitely worse than
Paul, but I want to give you guys that
that chance to give, you know, gives get
somebody that you can attack. So, um,
you can talk about either one. Jesus is
better than Muhammad, which maybe you
agree with. Uh, Paul is better than
Muhammad. So, you can either deal with
both of those or if you want to pick one
which one you want to deal with, you can
go ahead. You can unmute your mic now.
By the way,
uh, nice cheap shot by the way. I'll
give you that. I mean, you're known for
trickery and mockery, so I'll give you
that. You said you won't do things that
other people do, but you still went and
mocked Prophet Muhammad peace.
When did I say I don't do that things
other people?
Okay. Anyways,
yeah, I never said that. I'm going to
give you the same energy. I'm going to
give you the same energy. So, if you
come up here mocking and arrogant, I'm
going to treat you like mock anyone. I
didn't mock anyone.
I'm just saying. I'm just saying if you
come up here mocking, if you come up
here mocking and I'm going to treat you
that way.
No, no. You said Muslims mock Jesus
Christ. I just wanted one person to do
it because you know what? If
if I if I give you a name, what would
that do for you?
I will tell he's not a Muslim because
Islam clearly
No, no, they are Muslims though.
No, no, because Allah
you can't determine who's a Muslim.
Listen to me. Allah says in the Quran in
chapter 6 verse 108. Do not insult those
who invoke besides Allah. It's a clear
statement.
I know what the Quran says. Your Muslims
don't they don't care. They don't care
what the Quran says. That's the point.
So even so give me one name. One one
known person. One known person in
What do you mean known person? What do
you mean by known?
One person who's popular in the da scene
who mocks Jesus Christ.
Why why do they have to be popular in
the dawa scene? You said a Muslim. Now
now see you're doing the same thing that
Ali Dawa did. Because when I bring up
when I bring up Muslims that do this now
you shift the goalpost from okay don't
give me just any Muslim but give me
somebody who's popular in the Dawa scene
who who who openly does this.
These are the guys people listen to.
That's why these are the guys. If a
person does that on the street, it makes
no sense.
Do you have an argument against Paul and
Jesus or not?
Yeah, I will I will make an argument
against Paul and Jesus Christ. Firstly,
uh against Jesus Christ is it's not an
argument against Jesus Christ because
Allah has clearly said in the Quran to
not distinguish between the prophets. If
Allah says it, I obey. For me, all the
prophets are u we love all the prophets.
I cannot be a Muslim by compar comparing
between the prophets. That's a command
from Allah, right? You happy with that
answer? I haven't got anything else for
that.
Okay. So, pause there.
Okay. Pause there.
So, you don't believe that Muhammad is
the greatest example for mankind?
He's one of the best best creations of
of Allah. Yes, I believe that.
You believe that he's you believe he's
the best creation of all?
Yes, I believe that.
So, you're making a distinguishing
between him and
Allah says not distinguish between the
prophets and I'm not distinguish between
the prophets. That's my answer.
If if you say, hold on. So, so break
this down for me. Help me help clear
this up for me. If you say that Muhammad
is the best of creation,
yeah,
how are you're literally saying that
he's
better than the other prophets. He's the
best.
You just made a distingu. You just
distinguished him from the prophets.
The creations.
Are the prophets part of creation?
Yes. And Allah says, "Do not distinguish
me from the prophets and I'm not
distinguishing." I'll say to Paul, I'm
not going to go with Jesus Christ.
Hold on. Wait. Just saying that is not
dealing with is not dealing with the the
problem here. If you say that something
is better is the best, you're saying
that it's better than the others, right?
Yeah.
Okay. So, if Muhammad is the best of
creation and the prophets are part of
creation, then Muhammad is the best of
the prophets, right?
Yeah. But there are some things I
believe Jesus was better than Prophet
Muhammad, peace be upon him.
But that's fine. But you just
Hold on. Hold on a second. I I don't
think I don't think that you're getting
it.
Yeah. Okay. You just told me that the
Quran says that you are not supposed to
make any distinctions
among the prophets and then you went on
to make a distinction among the
prophets. You said you just said
Muhammad is the best among the creation
which includes the prophets. So
Muhammad's the best among the prophets.
So you just made a distinction between
Muhammad and the rest of the prophets,
right? If you want to say it that way,
yeah, go for it. Right. It's not It's
not that that's how I want to take it.
That's what you're putting words in my
mouth. I didn't say that.
I'm sticking to the Quran, right?
You said I'm putting words in your
mouth.
Yeah. Yeah, he did.
I'm going to give you a chance to I'm
going to give you a chance to be honest.
Did you or did you not say that Muhammad
is the best of creation?
Yes, he is.
Okay. Did you or did you not acknowledge
that prophets are part of creation?
Yeah. Did you or did you not acknowledge
that yes, prophets are part of creation
and Muhammad is the best of them?
Muhammad is the best of creations,
which includes the prophets, right?
Yeah. If you want to say that way, go
for it.
Is that how I'm taking it or is that
what you said?
How are you take it? I'm telling you.
The Quran says don't distinguish between
the prophets.
I I want to let you know, brother, that
everybody that's here.
I'll let you go. I just want to let you
know
2600 people watching.
There's 2600 people watching. Please
don't interrupt me at this point. Please
don't interrupt me.
There's 2600 people watching. Almost
2,700. There's almost 500 people
watching on TikTok and all of them has
just show just seen how you have just
been arrogantly stupid and you have
purposely been dishonest here. So, thank
you for showing that. This is what Islam
is. I appreciate you.